[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight all indications out of
Washington right now suggested military
strike against Syria could be imminent
president Trump tweeted as much this
morning warning Syria's ally Russia to
get ready because missiles quote will be
coming nice and new and smart speaking
of smart five years ago in response to
the last administration's planned to
bomb Syria Trump tweeted this quote be
prepared there is a small chance that
our horrendous leadership could
unknowingly lead us into World War three
well that was a wise response the kind
of could get you elected president of
the United States and yet here we are
once again on the brink of something
whose outlines and consequences are
unknowable and terrifying on Monday
night we spent more than 15 minutes
talking about that we asked what seemed
like the most basic questions about a
war in Syria questions the geniuses on
the other channels ought to be asking
but are not we're told we must attack
Syria in order to punish President Assad
for launching a chemical attack against
his own people last weekend it's our
moral duty endless seenin panels have
reminded us to uphold international
standards of behavior and punish war
criminals like Assad okay but are we
sure Assad was responsible for the gas
attacks many people claimed he was they
started claiming that within hours of
the attacks themselves before many of
the most basic facts were even known and
they're still claiming it but where's
the proof they have provided no proof
they've just made loud noises and
denounce the question askers that's not
enough as American citizens we have a
right to know why we're doing this the
second question we asked on Monday was
how would attacking Syria help the
United States
how would it help make us richer or
safer or happier you think our
policymakers would keep that question
foremost in mind always they don't they
consider the effect on America an
irrelevant consideration maybe even
offensive to consider they are highly
annoyed when you ask about it like only
an agent of a foreign government would
want to know how a us-led war might help
the u.s. well it's easy to understand
why other countries might want us to
attack Syria China for example they'd be
thrilled by it if you sought to displace
America as the leader of the world you'd
want it to weaken its military and go
broke
and nothing achieves that faster than a
pointless war as we've proved in the
recent past again those seem like basic
questions nobody bothered to answer them
or even engage we had senator Roger
wicker of Mississippi on the show Monday
to talk about Syria he didn't even try
to explain how a war there might help
the u.s. instead he suggested we were
agents of Putin the rhetoric of the left
has corrupted establishment Republicans
in Washington and that's not surprising
the two groups have a lot in common it
turns out other pundits and Shea's
lounge commanders accused us at
disloyalty to all without answering our
questions shut up they explained over at
CBS they responded with ridicule Stephen
Colbert hosts a Late Show on CBS you
might not agree with his politics but
Colbert is not stupid he's smart enough
not to engage in a conversation that
might reveal him as a mindless war
monger posing as a liberal so he talked
about pandas instead it is unprecedented
that the president's personal lawyer
gets rolled up by John in law everybody
is covering this that includes Fox News
whose Tucker Carlson last night wasted
no time and going straight at addressing
our national nightmare you know the
official story about pandas they're cute
but adorably helpless which is why
they're almost extinct but like a lot of
what we hear that's a lie and as it
turns out could easily kill you if they
felt like it thank God they don't yes
thank God they don't and thank God that
Tucker is covering what historians will
call there's a pandemonium now obviously
he didn't have time to cover the Michael
Cohen rape because he had to talk about
this very in-depth report
Colbert's bit went on for at least four
minutes we've condensed it out of
kindness while our original panda
segment lasted for 30 seconds at the end
of Monday's show and yet it's what CBS
jumped on in CNN and a number of other
outlets that have spent the last week
pushing this administration to war they
have no interest in explaining how
bombing Syria might help America they
don't care and so instead they make fun
of pandas there may be a real case for
war in Syria we'd love to hear it we've
been begging to hear it we love to hear
it from Stephen Colbert himself by the
way he's welcome here any time though of
course will never come